many of us grew up reading his tales on
self-destruction revenge and violence
tells of premature burials of ghastly
cats and ravens where the line between
the living and the dead is never clear
when you look deeper into the life and
works of Edgar Allan Poe and more
complex figure emerges beyond the
traditional image of the alcoholic pale
sickly author who has an obsession with
death Poe's life it was not easy and in
many ways it was tragic and his paths
crossed the Grim Reaper's many times but
in today's bar graphics we're going to
look at another angle of Poe the
athletic military man the rebellious
student the ruthless reviewer the father
of detective fiction and to satisfy
those with morbid fantasies we're going
to investigate the mystery behind his
death
[Music]
Edgar Poe was born on the 19th of
January 1809 in Boston from David and
Elizabeth two traveling actors Edgar's
life had barely started when he suffered
a double trauma on the December 18 11
Elizabeth died of illness perhaps
pneumonia or tuberculosis which were
both highly prevalent in the u.s. at the
time David died within a few days of his
wife the details about that largely
unknown according to one accounts David
was performing in Norfolk Virginia with
his traveling theatre company when he
also died of an illness but different
account tells us that by the time of
Elizabeth's death the Poe family was a
broken one David left the household
leaving his wife destitute six days
after his mother's death the orphaned
Edgar was fostered into the home of John
and Francis Allen of Richmond his sister
Rosalie was taken in by the Mackenzie
family also of Richmond's well big
brother Henry remains with his
grandparents in Baltimore John and
Francis Allen
where a childless couple and although
they never legally adopted Edgar they
considered him to be their son Edgar
called them pas and ma John was wealthy
merchants a self-made man from Scotland
while Edwards relationship with Frances
would always be deeply affectionate him
and John would frequently clash on the
7th of January 1812 Edgar was baptised
as Edgar Allen Poe the Allen family with
Edgar in tow later moved to London where
they lived from 1815 to 1820 during
these years the young Edgar learned
grammar Latin Greek and surprised
dancing the Alan's returned to America
in 1820 and by 1823 Edgar was studying
in a school run by one William Burke no
not the Body Snatcher of Burke and Hare
famed just a namesake but if you'd like
to learn more about Burke and Hare we
absolutely have a video on them we kind
of imagined the modern equivalents of
this would be Stephen King graduating
from Ed Gein hi-po was a very active and
athletic teenager contradicting the
common image of the sickly brooding
intellectual in the summer of 1824 he
became famous for swimming seven miles
up the James River against a heavy tide
that's almost three times the swimming
segment of an Ironman competition
apparently schoolmaster Burke followed
him in a boat in case he needed help
maybe that's what got Edgar going being
chased by a Scottish serial killer on a
boat is a pretty powerful motivator but
remember it wasn't actually him it was
just a namesake late
that year edgar authored his first poem
of just two lines last night with many
cares and toils oppressed weary I laid
me on a couch to rest which can be
paraphrased as I am going to take a nap
on the sofa in February of 1826 Edgar
enrolled in the University of Virginia
Charlottesville but his studies there
they were short lived the wealthy John
Allen had no intention to fill Edgar's
pockets with easy money so the freshman
had to subsidize his expenses with a
side hustle and that was gambling Edgar
accumulated $2,000 of gambling debts
which is more than fifty thousand
dollars in today's money John refused to
pay leading to a rift between the two
men a situation which would occur again
in the future that yeah Edgar couldn't
really catch a break during Christmas
holidays he was looking forward to
reuniting with his childhood sweetheart
and prospective fiance Elmira Royster
but Ella Mira's parents had pressured
her into dumping him for a wealthy and
solid businessman alexander shelton it's
understandable than in 1827 Edgar
decided to leave University and reunite
with his older brother henry and
baltimore still in need of a steady
income in may Poe enlisted in the US
Army under the name Edgar a Perry
private Perry did well in the army and
rose to the rank of sergeant major of an
Artillery Regiment in less than two
years not only that but he also found
time to write his first book of poetry
this was Tamlyn and other poems it was
published with the pseudonym a Bostonian
this booklet sold about 50 copies if you
come across a copy of tamerlane in your
great-great-grandparents attic you could
probably auction it for around one
hundred and seventy two thousand dollars
on the 28th of February 1829 Francis
Allen MA died from a respiratory illness
just like Edgar's biological mother in
the following years Edgar's behavior it
became erratic and rebellious probably
as a consequence of Mars death now
initially post him to like army life in
April of 1829 he applied to the West
Point Academy looking forward to a
promotion from sergeants and lieutenants
he entered the Academy in the summer of
1830 but by the following winter he was
doing his best to get kicked out once a
talented cadet Spirax up a hundred and
ten offenses and a hundred and six
demerits in two terms he was
court-martialed and tried at the
beginning of February 1831 for gross
neglect of duty so what was the cause
for his rebelling
again it all came from his relationship
with John Allen paw had remarries
perhaps too quickly with mrs. newest
Patterson who Poe disliked moreover
edgar discovered that John had sired
children out of wedlock the feud was
embittered by a letter written by Poe in
which he claims that John Allen was
seldom sober
Edgar wanted to leave West Point to
pursue writing at this stage but he
needed John's authorization for a
voluntary discharge when John now cold
and distant refused Edgar started his
self-sabotaging campaign he succeeded
and was kicked out of the army but not
before collecting donations from a
hundred cadets to fund his next book of
poems which was simply titled poems in
the summer of 1831 fate dealt another
blow to Edgar as it claimed the life of
his brother Henry yet another victim of
tuberculosis
Edgar's writing career it started to
pick up in the early 1830s in his short
story message found in a bottle won a
$50 prize from a Baltimore magazine in
1833 the problems was very welcome as
John had closed the coffers and his
second wife Louisa did not approve of
Edgar and the couple now also had a
biological son likely to inherit Allen's
wealth in 1834 John fell ill when Edgar
heard the news he tried to reunite with
him one last time they're not seen each
other since West Point Edgar rushed to
Richmond overcame Louise's resistance
and finally came face to face with the
now terminal Parr Thomas Ellis John's
business partner describes the tearful
reunion with what little strength was
left in him John stood up so did they
hug oh no John raised his cane and
threatened to strike him if he came
within its reach it was the last time
they ever met John Allen died on March
27 1834 and his will it makes no mention
of Poe
in the second half of the 1830s Poe's
writing career it took off or rather he
was always employed but he had a little
Fame and even less money
following his Mars death in 1829 Edgar
had developed a friendship with his
cousin Virginia Clem 13 years his junior
Virginia was the daughter of Maria who
was the sister of David Pope so she was
a first-degree relative of Edgar's via
his biological father not his foster
family this relationship was initially
an innocent one with Virginia acting as
a go-between for Edgar and a girl called
Mary Devereaux who he was trying to woo
by 1835 when Poe was 26 in Virginia only
13 the friendship was developing into
something else
despite Virginia's relatives best
attempts on the 22nd of September 1835
Edgar and Virginia married in secret
celebrating a public wedding the
following year Edgar even took in his
ons and mother-in-law Maria Clem he
nicknamed her muddy for some reason and
apparently loved her as a mother
addressing her as such in a poem and fun
fact hereafter Poe's death Maria was
completely destitute and was relying on
charitable donations and among the
donors was one Charles Dickens going
back to Edgar and Virginia the marriage
such a young age would certainly not be
acceptable by today's standards and even
back then it was frowned upon but some
authors claim that Edgar's and
Virginia's relationship it may have been
purely platonic the theory is that after
the death of both is biological and
foster mother's Poe had transferred his
feelings of filial love sueanne's marry
and in turn to Virginia you could draw a
parallel with Poe's work at this stage
namely the short story of mirela of
April 1835 in this story an unnamed
narrator regards with a feeling of deep
yet most singular affection my friend
Marella the to marry and Marella grows
obsessed with death and issues of
identity she dies in childbirth and the
protagonist decides to leave the baby
girl unnamed for 10 years as she grows
older she is uncannily unlike her mother
when the girl turns 10 the father agrees
to have her baptized when he chooses the
name Marella the girl immediately dies
uttering I am here the tale concludes
with my own hands I bore her to the tomb
and I laughed with a long and bitter
laugh as I found no traces of the first
in the channel or where I laid the
second Marella the tale features poser
purring topics of resurrection and
identity beyond death and consider this
the narrator and Marella are friends
before marrying just like Edgar and
Virginia and then here is a transfer of
identity from mother to daughter which
opens the door to more Freudian
nightmares than we could possibly handle
in today's video Marella and the husband
in the tale that a happy marriage so how
is Edgar's and Virginia's apparently it
was successful despite lack of money
Virginia had a deep admiration towards
Poe and always kept his portrait under
her pillow Edgar on the other hand had
started flirting with one Frances
sergeant Osgood but besides exchanging
letters there is no proof of
relationship Frances was being
unsuccessfully courted by another author
and journalist Rufus W Griswald keep an
eye on him these letters were enough to
enrage another lady Elizabeth LSU at a
crush on Pope her reaction caused a
scandal is she alleged Poe and Francis
had a physical affair she even spread
rumors that Poe was subjected to acts of
lunacy Virginia was unconcerned with
Poe's flirtations but this scandal
affected deeply a frail health in the
second half of the 1830s Poe went full
workaholic moving frequently across East
Coast cities looking for work in
magazines he did not neglect his
creative writing their publishing his
first known novel the narrative of
Arthur Gordon Pym in 1838 in the
following two years Poe published two
works his seminal collection of
groundbreaking short stories tales of
the grotesque and arabesque and a
treatise on shellfish the con College
assist book which he co-authored one of
these two books sold out in two months
and you can probably guess which one it
was no it was the shellfish run not even
joking I'm not going to comment on the
taste of American readers in the 1830s
but well this was actually Poe's only
commercial success in his lifetime a
book about shellfish in 1841 Potok a
position as an editor for Graham's
magazine which he also used as a
platform for his own short stories the
circulation of the magazine from five
thousand to thirty seven thousand
subscribers Poe even convinced Charles
Dickens to write for the gram but in May
Poe left the magazine handing over his
duties to Rufus W Griswald remember him
Poe wrote to her friends my reason for
resigning was discussed with the
namby-pamby character of the magazine
the salary moreover did not pay me for
the labor which I was forced to bestow
by that time Virginia had already fallen
ill to tuberculosis some say is a
consequence of the Ehlert scandal her
health worsened but Poe did not stop on
his street he was finally going places
in 1843 post hail the Goldberg won a
$100 prize from a Philadelphia newspaper
it was followed by a theatrical
production and a French translation
giving poem deserved public attention he
embarked on a tour of sold-out poetry
lectures moved to New York and was a sub
editor of the evening mirror it was this
paper that in January 1845 published his
most famous poem The Raven it became an
immediate nationwide hit so what
princely sum did Poe earn for this
masterpiece well that would be fifteen
dollars or about three hundred and
twenty-five dollars in today's money in
February Poe took control and ownership
of the Broadway journal but this did not
help him financially if anything he
accumulated even more dirt and the
journal shut down in January the next
year things started to pick up thanks to
royalties from publication about New
York's literary scene but life giveth
and it taketh away
Virginia's condition it worsened and by
early 1846 she was bedridden she told
friends I know I shall die soon but I
want to be as happy as possible and make
Edgar happy on the 30th of January 1847
Virginia Poe died of tuberculosis in
Fordham New York on her deathbed it is
claimed that Virginia blamed her death
on the jealous mrs. allit Poe's love for
Virginia it was consuming as was his
grief for almost two years he visited
her grave everyday keeping it fresh with
flowers so what future lay ahead of
Edgar Allan Poe now that his beloved
Virginia was gone but let's pause this
man's life for a while and dig into his
work a bit
po is remembered as a master of horror
and father of the modern short story he
composed his tales following two main
rules each story should be short enough
to read in one sitting and each word
should contribute to the overall effect
of the story his published work came at
the apex of the Gothic and romantic
periods endured a great influence in
Europe where he was idolized by Shalala
Larenz the movements of the French poet
Morty beyond horror his body of work
encompasses many other genres and in
most cases it's not easy to define take
the short story the Duke de la Malay a
French aristocrat and Ramon Dies have
discussed when a delicacy is improperly
served him he wakes up in hell and start
spotting his way out he challenges Satan
to a duel that alas the Prince of Hell
does not fence the next best thing is a
nice game of 21 or blackjack if you like
Satan can refuse a game of cards so
challenge accept it
the Duke a skilled gambler wins the game
and his freedom in four pages po defines
two characters sets up a conflict
establishes some devilish lore along the
way and crosses three genres comedy
horror and subtle satire of European
aristocracy another crossover of stars
he achieved was with the murders of the
Rue Morgue
there is some horror also here with a
killing perpetrated by a monstrous
assailant but most of all this tale is
the first detective story PO established
the basic archetypes of this genre the
same collection tales by EA Po features
of the gold-bug this is a slash
detective romp tells the story of a
narrator his volatile friends Legrand
and a freed slave Jupiter who decipher
an encrypted message to find a pirate
treasure the story is best remembered
for Legrand's used to frequency analysis
to crack the code and for the depiction
of jupiter to modern ears it's pretty
damn racist
thus assigning an important speaking
role and a great deal of action to a
black character in 1840s America was
seen as a rather progressive move
much of Poe's writing career was
dedicated to reviews of other authors as
a literary critic Poe celebrated the
works of Washington Irvin and Nathaniel
Hawthorne among the classics of American
literature but he was known and feared
for how he destroyed less skilled
authors this earned him the nickname of
the tomahawk man tackling the poems of
one William W Lord Papa Pines that the
only remarkable things about mr. Lords
compositions are their remarkable
conceit ignorance impudence platitude
stupidity and bombast for many father
specimens of your stupidity good Lord
deliver us novelists were no luckier
theater s-phase 1835 work Norman Leslie
was unworthy of a schoolboy there is not
a single page of Norman Leslie in which
even a schoolboy would fail to detect at
least two or three gross errors in
grammar and some two or three most
egregious sins against common sense
there only gets the full tomahawk
treatment is Morris Madison's novel Paul
Ulrich the book before us is to purely
imbecile to merit and extended critique
but we shall have no hesitation in
exposing fully before the public eye
it's four hundred and forty-three pages
of utter folly Baum mast and inanity but
Poe was not done yet such other works
which bring daily discredit upon our
national literature works of incongruous
folly plagiarism immorality inanity and
bombast Poe also attacked fellow
journalists editors and critics the
editor of Boston miscellany HT Tuckerman
was an insufferable tedious and dull
writer while critic Rufus W Griswold was
dismissed as a toady destined to sink
into oblivion yep same Griswold as
before write that
[Music]
pose reputation still today is one of a
heavy drinker but it actually it was
only after Virginia's death that he gave
into alcohol and even then you never
only drank in huge quantities the
problem was that even a small quantity
of liquor it could knock him out in
November of 1848 po was courting poetess
sera
Helen Whisman no relation to Walt
Whitman she was so concerned about his
reputation for drinking that she asked
for total abstinence from alcohol as a
condition of marriage po failed to meet
the request and Sarah called off the
engagements in the summer of 18-49 po is
on a lecture tour in Richmond when he
again met his once girlfriend l mirror
the one who had dumped him for the
businessman now Meera was now a widow
and the to rekindle their love affair in
August O'Meara accepted Edgar's proposal
and po must have been dead serious about
it as only two days later he joins the
sons of temperance a sort of Alcoholics
Anonymous for the 19th century
everything was working out fine and then
the chain of events started that would
lead to pose unresolved death on the
26th of September 18-49 po visited a
physician friends called John Carter he
was due to leave Richmond Virginia to go
to Philadelphia to complete an editing
job Carter advised PO to postpone his
trip by a few days but he decided to
leave anyway on the 27th of September
18-49 po left Richmond for Philadelphia
for the following six days he just
vanished a journalist called Joseph
Walker walking outside the pub Gunnar's
Hall came across a traumatized man lying
in the gutter
the man was visibly ill in a state of
confusion and addressed in worn-out
ill-fitting clothes the man introduced
himself as Edgar Allen Poe and asked for
help Poe asked Walker to contact one
Joseph Snodgrass a newspaper editor with
the medical backgrounds Snodgrass took
Poe to a hospital where he was treated
by dr. John Morin Morin noted down his
patient symptoms fever mania revulsion
to water and calling for somebody called
Reynolds Warren also asked Polk where he
had left his possessions but the writer
he could not remember on the 7th of
october 1849 Edgar Allen Poe died at the
age of 40 the reported cause of death
was Fred itis or swelling of the brain
his mother-in-law the hearing poet died
went to check on his cat Katarina and
found out that she had also died one of
the early reported causes of Poe's death
was alcohol
use this unverified rumor was spread by
poser bitchery more on that a bit later
other possible causes include
tuberculosis epilepsy diabetes and even
rabies the latter may actually be
consistent with Katerina's death author
Matthew Pyle offered another explanation
brain cancer
this is consistent with the symptoms
plus when Poe's body was displaced to
another burial in 1875 the coffin
brokens witnesses noticed a small clump
rolling inside post skull this could
have been they calcified tumor other
theories involve violent crime Poe may
have been assaulted beaten up by
ruffians as claimed in 1867 by
biographer
oak Smith the post body it did not
display any signs of violence and other
criminal theory involves coupang this
was a common type of electoral fraud at
the time gangs of thugs would abduct and
corrupt citizens from the streets and
force them into a disguise so they could
vote several times for the same
candidate the victims were threatened
with violence or rewarded with alcohol
intriguing theory mentioned for the
first time in the early 1970s and there
are some points in its favor baltimore
at that time was in the middle of a
local election gannis Hall was a polling
station Poe was wearing somebody else's
clothes
finally Baltimore's newspaper the
Republican and Argus published warnings
against keeping on the 1st and 3rd of
October so we searched the animatic
named Reynolds in local Marion
newspapers and we found that in
September there were two people called
Reynolds acting as district delegates in
Elkton just outside of Baltimore could
they be involved in the local Baltimore
elections was this a name that Poe heard
or read while being cooped we also spoke
with an oncology surgeon formerly one of
London's biggest cancer centers who we
were just called dr. n dr. M confirms
that tumor masses can calcify even when
the surrounding healthy tissue
decomposes they offered an additional
explanation for the clump rolling around
inside his head and that would be head
trauma not only can it cause death but
it can also cause a small bone between
the cheek bone and the jaw to fracture
and detach at this point it would be
free to rattle around inside the skull a
blunt trauma at the back of the head
would not leave injuries and Poe's body
did not display any sign of violence
there aren't many more theories so I'm
just gonna stop here guns are there they
would probably go with coupang + blunt
trauma but let us know your theory in
the comments
[Music]
on the 9th of october 1849 an obituary
of pose appeared in the New York Tribune
signed Ludwig we don't know if Poe's
death was an assassination but certainly
this article was a character
assassination while praising Poe's work
ludwig wrote that few will be grieved by
his death and that the writer had little
to no friends and led a dissolute and
dissipate life ludwig would publish yet
more articles praising Poe the author
while destroying Poe the man
exaggerating or inventing embarrassing
details these articles were now signed
with his real name Rufus W Griswold the
irony is that Griswold was Poe's
executor meaning he had the rights to
edit and publish his works for a nice
profit and he did all this while
cementing the image of the dissolute and
lunatic alcoholic that still survives to
this day so I really hope you learn
something new about Edgar Allan Poe
today please do share this video with a
friend if you fancy it now we had to
skip tons of stuff here in this video of
course but if you want to dig deeper
check out the website of the Edgar Allan
Poe Society of Baltimore at EA PO org
it's a real mine of free material
including his full works and if he hears
somebody repeating one of Griswolds
lives well just like Poe's Raven just
say Nevermore
you